actually rollo tomasi ruined church a
little bit this is a whole different
conversation but he made me like
because i'm gonna talk anyway he uh
because because
he pointed out these things that i
thought about but i couldn't articulate
like why like like that something didn't
feel right because there would be these
chastity speakers that would come to our
school because i went to catholic school
for 12 years right this is getting um
this is the first public school i've
ever been to um
and i'm getting my master's right now
which i know is like the what's the
little
like that i'm a phd yeah yeah yeah
for fun though i wanted to play um
semi-pro volleyball so i got my masters
so i could do it
but anyways he
and they would these chastity speakers
would come to our school and then
basically the girl would be like yeah i
got ran through in high school but yeah
like didn't say it like that she
wouldn't say like that
okay like obviously okay this is it
would be it would be
she would say it nicely right she would
not say i got ran through she would say
i was still lost i was so broken i was
right right yeah but then
but then i like stopped doing that stuff
and i found my husband and i remember
thinking like so you're going to tell us
all to wait when you did all that
right like
why but but here's here's the thing
and this is the this is and this is a
skill that women have to acquire
it is very very very very difficult for
a woman with a high body count to hide
her body count even if she doesn't tell
and again if you're with a man who knows
his [ __ ] if you're the man who knows
this [ __ ] you can't hide your body count
you just can't do it because dude i've
slept dude i've slept with so many girls
i know i know all the signs oh my god
it's ridiculous and so when i meet and
this is the thing this actually happened
when i first met dev
so when devin and i first started dating
i was sleeping with other people and she
was sleeping with other people we were
both very open about that
one of the guys one of the guys that she
liked she liked another guy i guess
she liked to i forgot who he was
but for whatever reason he dropped out
of her rotation and then another guy and
then there was some drama with with with
someone else and she was spending most
of her time with me but she was thinking
to her she was like why is it like i'm
tired of this cycle
and you know me and she knew i was not
even sure but i was like well the reason
why is because you did x y and z and
she's like you know what she's like i'm
39 years old she's like i really i'm
tired of doing this roundabout so you'd
only been divorced for six months and in
some months of dating she was already
she devin got married at 21 and got
divorced when she got divorced she was
39 so she was married for 18 years so
she had relationship skills she just
didn't know how to use them because she
was just kind of out there and so she
says look you're mr red pill whatever
whatever teach me train me and so that's
that's kind of how that's kind of how
that started all of that said
devin i knew that i knew that devin had
not been because most girls are on the
carousel through their 20s and 30s
devin was married from 21 to 39 yeah
and her fun after the divorce but i met
her five to six months after that so i
mean how high could her body count have
been i'll never know i don't care the
point is is that i recognize okay this
woman is 39 years old and i'm not
catching any hoe vibes from her the
reason why i wasn't catching any hoe
vibes is because she'd been married for
almost two decades so she didn't really
she didn't move and act and she didn't
move and act in such a way that now who
knows maybe she was a master of disguise
why do you always say she was a hoe on
your channel well because when i well
because when i met her that's what she
was okay okay she was you kidding oh my
god of course she was she's like well
just so you know i'm dating this guy i'm
like hey listen man like it's it's all
fun and games it didn't didn't hurt my
feelings because we were we were two
consenting adults so yeah when devin
when i met deb she was being oh and
she'll and she'll she'll say as much in
terms of endearment it is what it is but
but when you're with but if i had met
let's just say devon didn't get married
at 21.
got ran through her 20s and 30s
pardon me and i see her at the
baskin-robbins and we start talking
again
it would have dude honestly it would
have taken me a half a day to figure out
okay this [ __ ] has been ran through
like your girl that you're like your
girl the chastity now there are some
women there are some women who have
mastered the art
of hiding their body count in other
words
they have mastered the they have
mastered the traits that don't give away
that they've been ran through it's very
very difficult to do and if you're with
a guy who really knows what he's doing a
guy with a lot of experience it's not
easy to get one over on him i can't
imagine that it's happened too often but
the girl just like you said who got ran
through but found her husband i can
promise you her husband probably was not
that experienced that's probably why she
was
well well i think that's why
like when he described like the guys in
the church being like beta and being
like yeah then they'll like take on the
i'm like oh my god like
like
it's not it's not that many of the
church it's not that men in the church
are beta it's just that men in the
church aren't taught
that you it says in the bible the man
leads the household but that's not what
they're teaching in church because dude
if you ever put any of my videos my team
videos in a church oh my god what is
this blasphemy and da da da da listen
man the bible is as red pill as any book
that that has ever been written the
problem is is that the church is a
business and if you're not if you're not
putting out the message that people want
to hear the pretty lies instead of the
ugly truth you're not going to get as
many parishioners mm-hmm
well and
i don't know yeah rolo ruins church for
me i'm not even gonna lie like once i
i'm not even gonna like
once i saw it i couldn't un-change and
see it no
and i'm like oh my gosh um okay but so
so what i was going to say though is i
see girls with you know if again they
could be lying but let's just assume for
sure
let's say less than five bodies right
okay but then they get to a certain age
and they're used to like making a guy
wait right like months whatever but they
get to a certain age and even though
they have a low body count it doesn't
really matter anymore because they're
past a certain age that's right that
makes sense that makes perfect sense so
like and i feel like that stuff isn't
really like taught to women we're like
and that's where i see hoes get wifed up
faster that's right
very good okay i like how you brought
that around i'm like are you getting it
because and that's like the bad dating
advice that i think i see in the church
yes yes because yeah it's wacky listen
case and i don't like to bring in uh
celebrities or exceptions to the rule
but look at lolo jones lolo jones is
beautiful she's a 40 year old virgin
nobody wants to take yes nobody wants to
take the no one wants to take the
virginity of a 40 year old we want to we
want to take the virginity of a 20 year
old a woman in their 20s
nobody like rocky took adrian's
virginity when adrian was 31. good for
rocky and that was of course just a
story but but yeah like your virginity
is sacred but once you get past a
certain age it's like okay
like i mean is it really a hymen when
you're 35 years old or yeah i mean like
what are we doing here yeah you're right
and i think a lot of those girls um
like the
they're used to being able to like hold
out for a guy because they were young
before and maybe they don't especially
in the church there aren't a lot of guys
a lot of the time
so they're used to like when they find a
guy they like like making him wait and
him being willing to oh but like this is
and my church that i went to isn't as
crazy like you see a lot of like there's
not a lot of like the single mom
syndrome that like i didn't really see
that in my church i know that's common
it's common in black churches
i see single women but not single moms
that's what i see in my church oh i'm
with you i'm with you yeah the thing
about oh god churches are just
churches are like it's it's it's it's
kind of an anomaly but churches are
every bit as responsible for the
neutering of men as feminism is man it's
it's sad to see but but that's how it is
i mean listen i'm all about chastity and
this and that and the third but
and here's the thing let's go back to
your church in wisconsin let's just take
that scenario i haven't slept with your
25 year old virginal friend yet right if
i see that she really likes me i'm 44
she's 25 i'm like okay
like nobody has supposedly smashed this
girl
i'm not picking up any whole vibe she's
always she's always letting me know
what's up she's always over here blah
blah blah blah
now i'm not gonna i'll wait for sex from
her but if i do smash other girls i'm
not gonna let her find out and the
reason why i'm not gonna let her find
out is because i'm serious about a
relationship i am not about i am not
about to scare i'm not about to scare
off now she might have her suspicions
but
i'm i'm i mean i'm really good at hiding
my uh my extracurricular activities
hopefully
no she's in there um but uh but yeah if
if if if a girl is worth it to me
i'm not going to wait for sex because
i'm trying to [ __ ] but i'm not i don't
want to mess this up so if i am smashing
other girls there's no way i'm letting
her know about it
okay
so okay now